hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
thanks so much for being with us Biden
and Son America for sale that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
they've changed their explanations more
than Hunter's changed prostitutes I've
never spoken to my son about his
overseas it wasn't a discussion in any
way there's no but to this no we never
did the president was never in business
with his son Hunter may have put his
father on the the phone with any number
of different people and they never once
spoke about any business dealings it was
all casual conversation niceties the
weather he's like Susan Rice was during
Benghazi send him out
from Joe knows nothing to he may have
spoken to Hunter's business associates
but you can't prove any criminal uh
wrongdoing or that he actually helped
Hunter's clients
gosh they think you are this stupid
their new spin is about as convincing as
their new pitch that binomics is working
and do you see this today Biden's
overall approval is at an all-time low
on the economy just 34 so I'm telling
you Americans are not this stupid
facts are stubborn things people see
that as most Americans are getting
poorer the bidens keep getting richer
how is that happening and during the
past several years the evidence about
Hunter has pointed to one unmistakable
conclusion
the Biden family acted like the U.S
government was for sale
Hunter's old pal and business partner
Devin Archer testified on Capitol Hill
today and he confirmed what we suspected
before that Joe Biden lied when he said
he didn't know anything about his son's
business
well we all know that when he was VP Joe
Biden was put on phone calls with Hunter
and his clients not to discuss the
weather as fascinating as Joe's
perspective on the weather must be but
to reassure those clients that the big
guy was on their side
Archer testified that Hunter put his
father on speakerphone while meeting
with business partners at least 20 times
a lot of weather to talk about and said
that Joe Biden was on the phone to
basically sell the brand now now should
really get hung up as sometimes
Republicans are want to do on whether
sufficient proof exists to convict Joe
Biden of a financial crime that's
irrelevant here if Biden had any brains
he would never have wanted funds to go
directly to himself anyway it would be
better if it all went to his son or
brother or anyone in his family for that
matter as long as it went to a Biden
again consider what we already know
Hunter was promoting himself as someone
who could get things done remember the
WhatsApp message
we know that his dad was happy to
participate in these calls with Hunter's
foreign clients and I'm thinking about
this today I'm thinking imagine for one
millisecond if this same fact pattern
applied to Don Jr and Donald Trump
do you think the New York Times would be
defending their actions because there
isn't a Smoking Gun
there's never a concern about needing a
Smoking Gun when the bogus Trump
investigations are involved that's never
a consideration
we all know that Hunter was paid obscene
amounts of money for one reason and one
reason only
he could deliver results
what foreign Energy company or bank
would ever consider consider writing a
check for 10 million dollars as barisma
did and expect nothing in return just
nothing
do we think the Chinese energy firm cefc
it is basically a big conglomerate just
randomly wrote checks whether or not
they actually received services in
return the type of services that only
Hunter could provide
yeah that's the type of absurd argument
that the Democrats would have us believe
or to put it another way that Hunter who
had precisely no expertise in
international business essentially I
guess built his foreign clients cheated
them out of millions of dollars because
his dad just did nothing for them
come on we all know that's another lie
because we know Joe made it clear what
he would do to zelinski if the
prosecutor was not fired that just so
happened to be investigating barisma
I said you're not getting a billion I'm
going to be leaving here and I think it
was what six hours I looked I said I'm
leaving in six hours if the prosecutor
is not fired you're not getting the
money oh son of a
got fired and they put in place someone
who was solid
wouldn't investigate barisma now
remember how Trump was impeached over a
phone call trying to get to the bottom
of that
there's never been a time like this in
our country they go around indicting me
for nothing and this is a crime family
that was like Mobsters the way they
smoke on the phone the way he spoke on
the phone about his father sitting there
and he was sitting there he would does
anyone have a doubt about that
amongst the many shocking revelations
from Archer was this that Hunter Biden
and top Executives of barisma called DC
in 2015 to ask the Obama Administration
to help fire the Ukrainian prosecutor
investigating the firm that was today
now we asked from the beginning I think
the only question that really matters
here
how did the bidens get so rich and what
services were paid to Hunter Biden under
these circumstances
now at this point just to save the US
government any more money on these
investigations
we actually should consider getting
Congress just to pass something called
the Biden Family Support act for 2023
just appropriate I don't know 50 million
dollars to the family and be done with
all of them for once once and for all I
think about how much money we're
spending here I'm only half kidding
this has never really been a hunter
Biden scandal as slimy as he obviously
is
this has always been a Biden family
Scandal and everyone knows it
everyone in that hearing room today know
it every lawyer worth his salt knows it
every lobbyist every foreign official
so tonight I'm telling you this that
Democrats cannot keep spinning and lying
to us I mean they can try and they can
do it to themselves but it's not going
to change the following
that this Saga has formed another
political Cloud over Joe Biden that will
never depart
and if the Democrats continue to defend
this by hanging it all on legal
semantics no one is going to take them
seriously on any other ethical matter
not ever
certainly not involving Trump
how silly
and how hypocritical does Biden sound
when lecturing other countries now about
democracy or about the need to preserve
norms
Joe what Norms are those exactly
using your whacked out son to make money
but you know his dropping your name
putting you on the phone bragging about
how the vines always deliver then
leaving the customer with a what we're
supposed to believe a pretty box full of
air and yet they wrote these big checks
is this what democracy looks like Biden
Style
the best lawyer in America may never be
able to prove that Joe Biden had the
intent to solicit bribes and the Senate
probably wouldn't have the votes anyway
to convict him if he was actually
impeached but that is beside the point
it's not about whether Joe himself
committed a crime it's about whether we
really want to reward this family with
four more years in office
the Democrats just want us all to move
on
and yes we intend to
from the bidens and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else